- [Voiceover] If this pages
was folded along the dotted
line in the figure above,
the left half of the letter
W would exactly coincide
with the right half of W.
You see that right over there.
If you fold it, this point
would go to that point
right over here, this
point would go to that
point right over there,
that point would go to that
point right over there.
And I could keep going.
You have this axis of symmetry right
over here right down the center.
Which of the following letters, as shown,
cannot be folded along
a vertical line so that
it's left half would
coincide with its right half?
I encourage you to pause the video
and think about this on your own.
Well, let's just think
about each of these.
If I were to drop a vertical
line own the center of A,
it looks like A is symmetric about that.
There are mirror images on the left
and the right hand side.
Same thing for the letter I,
same thing for the letter O,
mirror images on the two sides,
same thing for the letter U.
Now, E gets interesting.
We don't have a mirror image.
If I were to take the
mirror image of this point
right over here, we would get
to this point right over there.
If I were to take the
mirror image of that point
right over there, well
that does get you to there,
but this point over here,
there's no corresponding
point on the other side here.
If I were to go here, there's no
corresponding point right over there.
In order for E to have been symmetric,
it should've either looked like this,
where if I were to drop
a vertical line there,
this would be symmetric,
or if it looked like this.
But obviously this is not
what the letter E looks like.
It does not look like
either of these symbols.
It looks like this and this
one does not have a line
of symmetry down its center axis.
A vertical line cannot be drawn down
its center to have a
line of symmetry here.
This is the one that cannot be
folded along a vertical line
so its left half would
coincide with its right half.